welcome all new subscribers after the
Logan Paul hey trans we're gonna don't
worry I'm not gonna disappoint what
you're subscribed for you're gonna get
okay so let's talk about some anime
that's where you subscribe Annie Mae
reviews thank you yes this is what
everyone wants from this channel you're
welcome everybody
Devilman crybaby came out on Netflix
last weekend I was pretty great by it
I thought the art style was so cool that
I was I had to check it out right away
this sort of glimpse of hope lit up
inside me huh is it possible Netflix
actually made something decent
in terms of anime no no Felix have you
already forgotten about blam your
favorite manga
what about definitely one of your
favorite anime they butchered it don't
let this abuse continue so I looked up
about devil man cry-baby
if there was reviews about it just so my
hope wouldn't be destroyed completely
and I couldn't find any I guess it was
just it just came out or something like
that but it made me look up where the
original came from and I looked up the
original manga and it's made by a jet
called gold and a guy now allegedly I
don't know for sure but people were
saying that he inspired can't with devil
man Kentaro Miura which is the creator
of berserk one of the greatest manga of
all time it's not but he did talk of
Miyazaki who created Dark Souls and
blood-borne and goat-cheese Sunnah which
is of course creator of legendary game
studio suit at 51 I thought that was
pretty awesome and I was like oh I can't
believe I never heard of devil man it
seemed like a really a big imprint in
Japanese animation nerd culture so I
decided to read the manga first
today it's okay it's it's okay basically
the devil man crybaby story is you have
a Kyra who is this very typical he's
kind of a loser he's a crybaby he
doesn't know how to fight and he then
gets to become half demon half human or
a demon with a human heart and me he
becomes devil man to fight other demons
it sounds extremely basic it sounds like
the plot of spider-man once you keep
reading you realize it's not it goes
from very cute to very quickly very dark
and very adult now apparently the manga
was originally a concept for a
child-friendly TV show
and also was made into an anime which
has the best English dub of all time
just just just watch this
think I give a [ __ ]
think again what I did like about the
manga was that it had an ending unlike a
lot of Shonen manga Naruto one piece
they just go on forever and there once
you get a hit you know you just keep
going and going
it's a story it tells it and that's it
it doesn't try to do anything else
although it's been apparently at that
readapted just a couple times just a
couple times we have Devilman anime
mazinger z vs devil made shin dabba man
true devil made double man the demon
bird devilment
Doshi devil main development lady again
the Dark Lord ever meant strange days
demon night great wall and that's not
even all of them it's really shouldn't
be a surprise looking at all this that
Netflix bought to do their own remake of
this for their platform but I think the
big surprise here is that it's good it's
really good I think why I really like
devil man cry-baby is because it's its
source material at least sets off to be
a typical superhero kind of story it's
it's really not and it uses that against
you to kind of throw you off and do
things that you wouldn't normally expect
it I think with this reallocation of the
anime they really took a lot of risk to
do some really crazy stuff and it really
paid off
starting off with the art style it's
very aesthetic I love the art style and
it's what drew me in first some of my
favorite animes are literally just
purely based of the art style and
our direction it's got this very clean
not your typical anime style it reminded
me a little bit of Kaiba the anime
mainly in the colors the kind of
yellowish tones even fooly cooly don't
hurt me for saying that it reminded me
of a little bit the animation really
works it's very silly at a lot of times
it's silly when it needs to be or wants
to be but it's also serious when he
wants to be which is it's a nice
contrast if you thought that the running
style in Naruto looked silly then you
haven't seen the running style in devil
man it's a it's 10 out of 10 it's the
best I run like this all the time
whenever I'm late that's how I decide to
run for extra speed and momentum so you
have this really amazing really
interesting art style but then there's
more you get the soundtrack which is so
damn good you got pieces with Simon DS
type of an homage to the cemetery is
when the manga came out and it really
works everything just works
but it also has some chillingly good
emotional pieces or one after another
there's so many great tracks on this and
I'm definitely gonna buy the soundtrack
when it comes out I really loved it
there's this one song that plays at a
certain time I mean I'm not gonna spoil
it but it was definitely my favorite
part of the whole anime might said was
sitting next to me when I was watching
it and she wasn't really watching but
she noticed that I remember she's saying
like oh that's a really nice song that's
playing and I was just like yes
yesterday no spoilers but since I read
the manga there's a character deaf in
the story I read the manga so I knew he
was coming but the way they dealt with
this a hundred times better than I could
ever ask for it was it was a truly
beautiful moment that really caught me
off guard and that made me their stop
just to really think wow this anime is
really incredible you you got you got
incredible art style you got incredible
soundtrack and you got a great story and
all these three things really tying
together so nicely and that's why I
really really loved it and that's why I
really love anime and I have all these
different elements of art coming
together and it's it's very nice it's a
very nice and they really pulled it off
here in double men cry-baby
in the anime they tried to give some
characters a bit more depth they they
added the whole story about running the
characters past the pole to each other I
don't know what that sport is called in
English but they added that to give the
character more depth and it made works
to a certain extent I I think that the
characters are a bit shallow in the
manga and they unfortunately still are
in the anime I didn't really care too
much about a lot of them and they could
probably wasn't that important now what
really annoyed me the most and probably
the biggest flaw the anime and why I
think I read polygon calling it a
masterpiece I'll tell you why it's not a
masterpiece because the last episode
really falls flat I would almost
recommend that you don't even watch the
last episode of the anime and
read the manga it has a plot twist and
it's a really good plot twist but in the
anime they sort of just went tada
but didn't expect this huh yeah well in
the manga it's it's more of
understanding it yourself sort of
putting the pieces together and then
having this realization oh this is what
happened and that's really cool you
think this is just a your typical shown
in superhero anime or manga but it's
really not and he uses that against you
to deliver this plot twist which I
thought was really cool and really
clever and it it also also the manga
really brings up some interesting themes
about what it means to be human what it
means to be good or evil if the if the
manga poked these things with a stick
the anime just sort of like glances over
it like okay we're not gonna go near
that but overall good job Netflix you
finally did it you've made something
good and that deserves a round of
applause I'm gonna give devil man
cry-baby
a solid I want to give it an 8 but it
says seven point eight it's a seven
point eight strong art style I'm gonna
give a nine soundtrack I'm gonna give it
a nine I didn't like the intro and the
outro that much and the art style
unfortunately seem like they did lose a
lot a bit of budget because a lot of a
lot of backgrounds are just black a lot
of backgrounds are replaced with this
ugly textures it looks terrible so I
can't give it a ten even though I want
to
and then the story you tried it was all
right what did you think about diplomate
baby let me know in the comments I
really I really I'm just happy I think
the reason why I really really like it
is because it had that one moment that I
talked about and that just sort of
redeemed every quality every bad thing
for the anime if to be honest I think
that's how I look a lot of times on
anime there's this one bit that really
struck a chord with you that really
resonated
left an emotional impact that's how I
pick my favorite animes if they have
that one moment right I go holy [ __ ]
that really that was amazing and the
devil man crybaby had that for me so I'm
very grateful for that and I'm very
grateful for everyone working on it and
I'm talking too long so goodbye and
remember to leave a like we're almost at
60 million subscribers subscribe for
more anime reviews everybody and I'll
see you next Wednesday for another Logan
Paul video every Wednesday now squad for
now